foreign
this morning basketball star Brittany
Greiner tried and failed to overturn her
prison sentence Greiner has been held in
custody since February when airport
security in Moscow found a small amount
of cannabis oil in her carry-on luggage
she says that a doctor prescribed it for
her pain but a Russian Court sentenced
her to nine years in prison the U.S
state Department says Griner is being
wrongfully detained MTS tyus has been
covering this morning's appeal court
hearing and P.S good morning to you this
this outcome was not unexpected was it
good morning well it's the news Griner
her fans and loved ones have been
dreading her appeal to have her prison
sentence reduced has been denied by the
three Russian judges presiding over the
appeal
Brittany Greiner appeared in court via
video link from a Russian jail where she
learned the gut-wrenching news her
appeal was denied by the three presiding
judges and she will now likely be sent
to a penal colony after telling the
court her initial sentencing wasn't fair
very very stressful and a very dramatic
amount of mental and psychic being away
from my family and not being able to
communicate Griner was detained at a
Moscow airport after two small
cartridges of Hashi soil were found in
her suitcase back in February
Days Later Vladimir Putin launched his
invasion of Ukraine he saw ties between
Moscow and Washington disintegrate and
Greiner has been in jail ever since
that's Russian MVP speaking to Gail King
earlier this month greiner's wife
shirelle says she feared for the worst
wgs now in the position where she could
be moved to a labor camp
and
I
my brain can't even fathom it in August
Griner pled guilty for traveling with
the small quantity of hash prescribed to
her in the U.S for medical purposes
saying she packed it accidentally and
had no Criminal Intent Sherelle Greiner
says it feels as if Britney is being
held hostage that must scare you it
terrifies me because
I mean when you watch movies like
sometimes those situations don't end
well sometimes they never get the person
back so this is not a movie though
exactly and this is my life and so I'm
sitting there like do we get her back do
I ever get to see my wife again
now there is a glimmer of hope for
Brittany Griner Bill Richardson a former
U.S ambassador to the UN who traveled to
Moscow in September says he believes
Griner and former U.S marine Paul Whelan
who's also being held in a Russian
prison could both be released in a
potential prisoner swap by the end of
the year Nate wow that sounds like good
news if that is indeed the case and TS
tie up in London thank you so much yeah
we hold on the Griner family says they
hold on to all glimmers of hope I
checked in with shirelle last week just
to see how she was doing she did get to
talk to Brittany on her birthday for
just five minutes but she says she's
very worried about her wife's mental
health and that Britney's main concern
is that she worries people here in this
country will forget her and that
certainly isn't going to happen we won't
forget her no